he survived yeah we're on the other side
of probably the most harrowing episode
ever wasn't pretty um some people
pointed out that our gameplay audio was
super loud compared to our voices I
apologize for that I'm usually doing the
sound over here so hopefully we got a
fix for this episode but judging by
people's Twitter responses they could
hear clearly what I said when you uh
were [__] up Lefton right Jes I'm
just kidding I'm kidding Jesus [__] was
my favorite yeah cuz I okay throw the
flashbang at the ground and you into the
air so my direction was downward but uh
anyway I survived that's the point uh
the point is I survived uh We've we're
actually okay here look at this we have
uh you know I got my regular gun with 22
I got some ammo uh I have full health
because I got to a checkpoint and I got
two first AIDS and I got a red um o wait
uh I people have been yelling at me
saying that you can combine greens I
thought that it wouldn't increase the
power of the greens but I got so many
comments I looked it up and sure as [__]
combining two green herbs is more
valuable than just eating them
individually so I've been I've been like
making mistakes left and right whoops I
guess that's new I didn't know that I
cuz I knew in previous ones you're not
supposed to do that uh yeah I didn't
know that we can you can double check
their work double check our work but I'm
pretty sure anyway so I I bought
everything I could mhm at the end of
last episode which means I should be
ready to go wait you did what' you buy I
don't remember oh yeah you got for one I
got those two first AIDS I'll tell you
that right what are you buying and then
I can oh it looks like oh no so I've
already boughten all this boughten I've
already purchased all these items
mhm
um so yeah I think I should be good okay
um I was hoping I could buy ammo but it
looks like you can't um but when you
upgrade a gun it replenishes your ammo
the I think the ammo capacity
specifically yeah yeah cool
open so oh [__] wait
what um [__] what I am only just
considering now what's about
[__] is this a boss
uhhuh there's if you go down though
there's ammo you just need to dodge him
for a
while ah you just missed her the ritual
is over she left with my men to an
island
[Music]
what are you suggesting that it's going
to be almost impossible for me to beat
this boss being on of ammo that I have
no no well you have ammo like
down
welcome a
a
[Music]
ah oh my God all
right there it consume
no
okay
I
look
afraid it's got one
eye
lot
e monsters guess after this there'll be
one less to worry
about I want you to suff just
like all so in those barrels
I have sum
yeah getting some bad drops here oh I
got to kill
that
red so what should I do uh yeah c
those come on
TMP okay cool
cool um all right so those are going to
keep coming so I need to figure out what
to do immediately go get the
rest oh
those only if I get good drops man
historically my drops have been
pretty
bad that was a
[__]
die okay you're good on health for the
first time in the
series all right so all right let's talk
about this I got a oneeyed tentacle
dude I feel feel like I should be
shooting him in the
eye uh I would go back up I
guess drop drop
drop do those uh tentacle things come
up yeah excuse how do I get up the
ladder all right
so
you that
iBall
um
need okay sorry my
B
maybe all right so don't let that
happen
God there's so
many so I've shot him
once he's very
movy got a that's didn't give me the
Dodge
option I did
it
but I did the thing all right this might
take a couple tries so worst case
scenario if you do die you're there's a
merchant you can just spend a fuckload
of money on new weapons and you'll right
and that's really not like I think
you're fine with ammo actually now that
I see how much shotgun sh how
shot so like where should I is there
like a better
area
okay so now just [__] do what
rock
okay and now eyeball yeah but you also
got to make sure it's going to like wind
up
Attack definely One shoot it for
stop
moving oh sorry I didn't know that that
okay I think I died so the best way to
stop that is this I this might sound
shot in his eye shoot his eye you it'll
give you like a brief second when his
mouth is opening to shoot the eye and
you can like Parry it almost but I think
you're good on ammo actually want me see
your inventory but I got drops again
remember and the shotgun is not really
helpful it is you're close enough for it
to be helpful not against against the
eyeball that is cuz you don't have to it
helps when it's opening it mouth the
shotgun spread helps it aim more okay or
you don't have to aim as precisely all
right
so I should skip
this skip uh touch pad I want you to
suffer just like
Ashley you see what you can do before
going down oh
okay
don't let it get you oh right go wait
what was I supposed to do uh shoot the
eye and it's opening from what I
remember that happened
wow um that's a oneit
kill did I not have full health you no
you were pretty low I think what oh
[__] I want you to suffer just like I
[__] you you little
stupid the shotgun would be good right
now you have the AIM as I didn't
know like am
I like what it was just bad timing I
guess
like I don't understand at least this is
like relatively not painful to do this
like it's starts me in a really good
spot
okay I like I actually I still I don't
get it just
like oh
[__] okay and then I should change to my
other gun and shoot that baby
mhm
Oh see it's
opening like when do I shoot the baby
need the ey
open I wonder how much damage I got to
do that
baby
wait
okay is the face
opening okay cool that went well that
went really
well okay got it got it oh
no so I had to dodge and then I had to
run one of your kills are
pretty pretty aggressive cuz now I have
to start over all over again and I was I
was doing pretty good mhm yeah I just
can't make like any mistakes just like
got it no
mistakes no
mistakes stop
moving stop moving
so can you be on like mouth Duty and
just let me know when that mouth is
opening MTH Beauty
Mike okay so I will shoot the eye with a
shotgun
instead cuz I'm running out of these
bullets how does that
sound uh
yeah
[__] you
eyeball got it got it got
it
no okay I'm just running I'm running
for
help
[__]
you I'm running out
of this is really
hard got
him got
it that goes down baby comes out one two
three what would
you
suggest
gotcha all right well I'm like seriously
running out of ammo I think I should go
down what do you think
yeah there
spiders oh they're all over the
place I'm out of
ammo can I knife them
uh cuz I like don't have any ammo can
try like what's that I don't want to use
my Magnum
ammo what's that my
rifle none of these are good
systems don't want this like I'll take
it not
effective
[Applause]
just flash grenade kill those
things uh the bugs yeah actually oh [__]
yeah now I think about it probably does
I have one
flash
thought uh throw in the middle of
him I hate that that thing one
hit yes nice
okay we're doing okay
off oh that came out of
nowhere all right here we go we're we're
doing
okay I'm going to I'm going to eat this
just in
Cas all right so I got a gun but I have
[Music]
to oh my God I'm
like shut up no I don't have the
ammo that tickle I
know
oh
baby baby
baby mouth mouth mouth baby baby
baby what's happening I'm
falling three more
hold
sorry hey mouth mouth mouth
mouth baby
baby that
tick
[__] [__] I really don't have the ammo
for this situation pull out your rifle
the
tentacle should I am I there
yet um rifle I think
rifle wait you mean this shotgun rifle
or shotgun cuz I have to reload the
rifle
yeah first try need no Magnum
round got it also the worst high five
ever was awkward the moment has
passed the Western grip of high fives
you know what that I don't know what
that is that's B joke
oh my hand was out man do
that well that went better than what was
that third try a
western kids with your window
though yeah I went really well for like
excuse me like I feel great about
it um that was probably like what my
fifth attempt and the attempts that
weren't go working weren't going well
was because it was like one hit kills it
wasn't wasn't like you know I was like
messing up yeah like every one of those
seemed fairly reasonable in
my humble
opinion that baby was
rich somebody left that baby a trust fun
just fun baby all right um anything else
that I missed
any secrets that you know of in this
area I don't think so moving
on I apologize I haven't eaten lunch so
I'm eating
like I feel like I should be able to
open
this that just like looks opening um
eating like some yogurt and some trail
mix to satisfy myself
s is already dead he is MHM oh that was
the baby so
like [__]
hell sorry snakes I'm honestly snakes I
don't no snakes I'm just so
glad
I'm I'm so grateful that that just
didn't happened last episode remember
cuz I was on so little Health that I was
terrified that any Barrel could contain
a snake and just end everything that
would
have far for the course what's that
noise oh it's me got
it after like the time I've had I'm
actually oh good I'm always like
paranoid about like I'm just gonna like
find a Gigante around a Gigante around
like a corner or something is going to
end
me I feel like it's safe to say that if
I didn't get a Ruby from like forever
though I'm not going to get
one yes
yes yes it's going sick yeah um and I
have like I'm super St things on sale
stranger so all I need is what are you
selling um not oh wait my TMP ammo you
can have that is that all
Str thank you so I have some
gems and I got this Spinelli is that old
stranger I'm keeping these gems yes we
haven't decided that these go in
anything yet uh or I've missed it
I can hold on to look it up right now I
can hold on to them let you know about
for the next Merchant I actually
honestly don't even know okay I haven't
read comments yet usually people point
that
out um what's
exclusive oh that like makes it it's
like I'm yeah get that makes it like o
it's it's expensive mhm it's worth
it is that old
stranger thank
you uh my Riot gun
capacity probably wait damn it I just I
just
reloaded such a dumb don't do capacity
yet then okay so should I do
[Music]
Firepower sure I'm rich is that
old CES I
got fcking rolling in
it
[Music]
all
right I think that's
it what are you buying no treasure map
right so I still can buy a rocket
launcher I don't need it right now is
that what you're
saying did you not get that other one
what do you mean there's a glass cave
with an RPG in that like room back what
I thought you got
it what or did you use it I used one on
the ice
guy yeah yeah you it it's
gone like you use up the rocket and it's
gone right so do I need to buy a new
[Music]
one you don't need to no okay I mean
it's helpful for
Saddler uh is that coming
up uh no it's the last one okay what
chter are you in I don't
know I think it said on that save but uh
yeah if you don't have
the elegant mask anymore sell those
gem hey
girl need a ride handsome
woohoo okay
[Laughter]
yes hit ratio back on top my game is
strong we're getting close enemies
killed a lot numbers of times killed
more than normal save
yes so I've just
finished
five what do you mean five chapter five
four no you just finished four oh I'm on
I'm on chapter 5 I think are you I don't
know I saw the number five
oh this is story
evening I
guess got some business to take care
of see you later he's
ridiculous
she's ridiculous it's unnecessary for
her to be like this did you say women
yep well feel like we deserve that
one she didn't do much I hate to break
it out to you but Salazar is dead break
it out to you it just means break it to
you Sadler why don't you give up and let
Ashley go home perhaps you are
disillusioned with
overconfidence just because you killed
my small time subordinate
Sadler your small
time arrive in my cage of Torment my
friend where am
I uh just like an island off the castle
thing
SP I
guess look at this long
snake I'm to fight that
later left or
right taking that [__] up
there
oo all right is that
it there that but I don't know how to
get
there I think it's by going
right
it's not her name
Ivanka we're coming for you
Ivanka
uh-oh uh-oh wait they're wearing Army
jerk
now let
me obviously you've never been in the
army army
jerk like gar oh
okay that went in my [__]
head I
think no
that is that all you
got
I think I was trying to say Garb and it
came out
jerk let's be real
the that's such a waste of
ammo
don't look I'm behind these
boxes
shoot
oh got you so
yeah like got hit high enough am I safe
I'm an
idiot what he
sa what a battle it's
like I think I'm hit
him the battle of the
windows
what a
maroon now
I like chains or
something looks like this reflector
rotates rotate sure
I
see you going to like come up here
what can hear
him oh here you are
I'm
coming your alien
head
oh no there's a guy with a
shield okay
work what's going on like coming in
sun look so dumb like this Vietnam I'm
going to [__] die
okay I know you guys had a crazy week I
mean it was like
oh my God there's too
many I'm
up my little safety
note all right let's talk about
this
feel like that was a good
decision an
alien and then I need to just kill that
alien I do have a flash but I'm going to
sa I think I need to
down he just keep coming up like is this
like like how many are
there someone
shooting arrows at
me oh
no how many of them are there I'm
actually like there's a lot of
guys uh yeah I
guess oh
God
what should I do
shotgun probably I only have one
shot got him ad oh he's
alive like I need to get that stuff down
there but there's a lot of dudes down
there what should I do
how many are
there no
regrets was it worth it yeah
where is the other
ladder to your left somewhere I
think hey
blink feel like I lost some ammo in this
transaction
yes walk over slowly to me
please
gotcha okay cool I feel like I've done
it I didn't do everything good but did
most things
good the music's still
pumping you K the machine gun
yes but I got to get up
there yeah I don't know where the ladder
is oh is it that
one yeah okay
cool I mean is that
it
it's so
much like there's definitely still
intense
oh so
wait that one should be hitting that one
and then that one hit
that I hope that laser stays on it's
really it like it's like kind of
a
cool not a puzzle it's like that thing
where it's
like if you get in the way of the laser
it cuts your head
off
and then the door
melts
like remember that time the door melted
and I was like they built this whole
thing for one
person one time that can happen and then
they're like our door melted we have to
construct a brand new one
again
oh no oh no oh no
no oh jeez I feel like you're meant to
warn me that Stu
I I have not killed any snakes in this
game I've been so unlucky
with it's like they're going to do
something
here
damn
[Music]
it I just don't even think I can take
one more hit though that's the
problem
I can probably
take
B oh
[Music]
no
you will not stop me from getting this
stuff over
here poor bunch of
aliens
nothing what we even doing anymore ooh I
should have stayed down hey
look at this
guy do not have an alien in
your what what is even up here why did I
do that oh was this just like save me
some time
later this area is
weird I really like that everyone told
me that the best part
is
um the mansion that's like the fun part
that everyone's like
yeah I don't
understand is this just a
view just like a nice looking thing so
that was where I was supposed to
go so I killed this
guy and I jumped over
here and now
what I guess I'm supposed to jump
wa all right I'm I'm on
board
hear
him
window I'm
P what's
that who's shooting at me
thank
you
no there's an alien in that
guy oh he's going to hit
me for butt
sakes what but sfe yes it was like so
little that could be done with
us I'm so done [__] around who's
shooting
me oh you have a thing
on
cleaner someone made a comment once on a
video that said like oh the third
character dude you do live on your
phone okay it really is I know we got we
have a tomorrow actually by the time
this oh is that
you what do you do then what do you do
else
promise
so wait is that a secret uh sure or is
that where I go
next I'll say oh
God this little
secret oh wait is that implying there's
traps I don't think I think that's
saying is a trap oh pretty implication
it's a implication climb
up oh wait maybe you are
right no yeah open maybe there's a
painting on the
wall the golden links cool don't jump
onto those stop I'm trying not
to I feel
like this guy died so that I could get
that
links
and it was in vain cuz I'm just going to
sell it I don't appreciate it at
all
Cool Secret found on my
own I don't
need
anyone changing to better
gun
okay
look at you
idiot that
Barrel oh for [__]
sake why didn't I zoom in before
what's going
on this
area like I don't hear
you I think he's behind
me don't have an
alien
no you should be more involved in this
process
no
wait um maybe I'll get a yellow as well
we hold
up what is going on over
there woo he's killing his own kind an
idiot
[__] okay so I
hear alive
people
oh I like these guys they walk really
slow and they don't have anything like
what is this plan when he gets to
me I think
I'm why are you so jumpy right they keep
coming out of
tunnels
die
die that was
lucky the tunnels dude
like oh
yes
cool very well fairly
well all
right oh I could have made this I see
this is what you okay I can't like
remember everything I've played this
game like a month ago uhuh longer than
at this point well we might as well do
it
now how do you set it
off a that would have been so
cool
sorry you're fine got here by
yourself no mic or cart
heed what what do you do here
here you watch mad man ever welcome um
yeah I didn't finish it though got some
rare things on I want to say more than
halfway to where some pretty interesting
spoilers
Asen that I can't talk
about that
halfway yeah where like someone was fat
and then all of a sudden you were like
oh sorry
what are youing having a baby
so I
didn't that wasn't halfway through the
show that was like end of season 1 was
it
yeah well beginning of season damn I
didn't I didn't do it
again which rifle do I have is it this
one yes okay
I
[__] have zero bullets on this one on
purpose
nice yeah get 24 free bullets I planned
this I don't remember the shotgun
though is that old
stranger thank
you come back I was very I was very
impressed with myself I was like no more
of that gun Mary shotguns the
same damn I'm any time no open your
jacket back up I'm not done
here what are you
buying that makes me feel really good
like really smart is that all
stranger thank you bunch of Dum Dums I'm
just breaking it in anything else what
are you selling also did we learn about
the
mask uh yeah we passed it can I put the
gems in the
links
no okay I think things go in the link so
I just sell these gems look at the links
the description yep three
holes
Sorry probably need some sort of cat eye
oh [__] the cat eyes I don't know what
that is from
earlier what do I do with this
Emerald maybe that Emerald goes in the
cap anyway these purple gems I'm selling
right sure all right is is that old
stranger 9,000 from them is that old
stranger is that old
stranger thank you um anything else what
are you buying island treasure
map no people keep saying get the
treasure map we'll get through the game
without trying to
Res and finally I can
assume command of evil I have an agenda
here I have a plot that's been work in
the work since the idea for the show
came up soon you'll all see soon you
will all see what am I doing with those
green emeralds you seem fine with my D I
have no I I don't understand what it
means so it like has no value to
me all right that's one thank you guys
for watching
[Music]
no deaths next episode I except for that
boss turn my phone off burn
it that's a good that was like exactly
half an hour a little less
what little less than an hour for that
episode yeah it was like 1 hour like
spot on I'm [__] I'm killing it right
now
yeah well I thought it went well you
weren't there we wouldn't know I
was you're like an object
father when you're coming home son I
don't know when we can get together then
we know we'll have a good time
there like Canal d